ooh what was that I love to see
horizontal poy there's not nearly enough
of that out there that's just the most
awkward way of doing that hey there what
do we have here anti-bds you love to see
it hey there friends Drex here from Drex
Factor po sharing with you the love of
Po spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain and today I'm going
to be checking out a viral POI video
that has been making the rounds the past
few weeks before we dive in though I
just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyrro Tera light
toys spinballs and Ultra PO for helping
them make the videos on this channel
possible you can learn more about all
these awesome companies and the work
that they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non-b buus friend of the channel Becca
beinen thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission so it has been a long long time
since I've done a reacts video um I
think it's been more than a year and
there is a video by a uh European po
Spinner by the name of uh Boris Mallette
Malay I'm not quite sure how to
pronounce it that blew up on Instagram
in the past few weeks I think it is over
200,000 views as I'm recording this and
I thought it'd be a good opportunity to
do another one of these his video is
only a few seconds long so this video
will not be super long in and of itself
but hopefully there's still something
that we all can get out of it all right
so let's take a look at this video from
Boris and see what he's got going here
cool that's a nice head swap oh lovely
so I really like that toss that he was
just doing there if we go back for a
second here um
so once he makes this catch here this
toss that he does where he is looping uh
the Handler around one hand and uh
basically doing an isolated throw on the
bottom I remember seeing Mel do
something similar in a video that he
posted like a year ago to celebrate his
birthday that likewise I just thought
was a a really really brilliant move um
the way Boris is doing it um he's very
specifically using his hand to steady
the top poy which is a smart move
because the top poy was definitely the
one that I had a hard time with as I was
learning that toss from Mel cool we got
some meteor spinning nice toss ooh
that's such an interesting choice if we
back up here after does the toss um he's
in a spot where the PO are coming down
on bottom in together same and he does a
little thing over the top here this is
actually a really really subtle move his
left hand is performing an extension
while his right hand is basically doing
a tratra here so this is a uh poly
rythmic move and it means that the PO
are both pointing down at the same time
but once we get to the top one's pointed
up all the other one's pointed down it's
interesting because because so far
everything that he's done has been just
in a single timing in Direction here
like if we look back we're in Split
times same direction for all intents and
purposes split opposites split times
same direction and now we're in a poly
rythmic place so we're using a move
where he Cycles through multiple timing
and Direction modes there between uh
together same and uh excuse me it will
be yeah together same and then uh split
time opposites there at the top it feels
different in this performance simply
because it is very much which of these
things is not like the other in that
regard oh that was cool this thing he's
doing for just a hair of a second here
is actually a cat eye versus uh versus
pendulum but it's being done in a hands
together place instead of the anti-rid
arrangement that it's usually done in if
you look at the movement of his hands
right quick they're both kind of tracing
out a circle the size of an isolation
here
and we've got his right hand performing
uh the cat eye which is
cool oh Nifty so um this kind of like
right
angle uh stack that he's doing right
here this reminds me a lot of uh a trick
I remember seeing Ronan doing about a
decade ago in a performance he did for
the British juggling convention um he
would take it uh back and forth and uh
create right angles with each hand uh I
think Boris only does it on the one side
here but yeah that's pretty cool I am
also just going to mention this right
quick but like there is definitely the
uh the cliche about tech pois Spinners
kind of locking their legs in this like
broad stance that we refer to as a tech
tree boris' stance here is much more
narrow but it's kind of the same idea
it's very riveted in place it's almost
like he looked at people doing Tech
trees and was just like hold my beer
cool so we got a r
ooh what was that so I think if I'm not
mistaken that toss that he's doing right
there is passing between the other Po in
the hand that it was once attached to
let's see if I'm right here yep yeah
right there right there it passes
between them that's so fast and subtle I
wouldn't have caught that if I were not
thinking of what to look for there
there's a throw that goes over past his
left arm and as he catches the two poy
uh this is almost like a line that You'
use for like a um a stall Chaser but
instead he's kind of turning it into a
body Tracer taking the uh the lead po
back behind his
shoulder oh yes oh what do we got there
we got some plane breaking I love it so
so we're going
from split Time same direction popping
into together opposites and winding the
tethers around his hand to Short shorten
them up and boom when he goes out to the
side he's switching into a cork screw
there for just a
second awesome I think though probably
he's getting it from the same place that
I did which is uh G the uh the British
po spinner um who was Super Active back
in the late 2000s and who really put
plane breaking on the map but that's
cool you love to see plane breaking I
love to see horizontal po there's not
nearly enough of that out there give me
more okay so he's finally move what what
so he's finally like moving his feet and
turning which is good I like Po
Spinners um kind of exploring the space
around them but damn isn't that like
just the most awkward way of doing that
turn he's basically pivoting on his heel
here and that's a really weird way to do
that step I'm glad there's a turn in
there but
like that's just the most awkward way of
doing that another toss between the hand
and the hand handle this one this one is
slower than the other one it's easier to
tell what's going on there hey there
what do we have here I like this why do
I like this I don't know if this is his
intention or not but this is an anti-
breed alignment right here so we've got
the alignment of one handle and one head
so a handle and a poy head going around
like a
butterfly um but it's not the handles
that are together we've got one head
that is together with a handle an
hibrids you'll love to see it
cool
what what was that that's a weird sort
of like little conveyor belt that he's
doing there with his contact
work okay that is the first thing I've
seen in this video that I think I would
have a uh a a a challenge doing myself
wow okay that's wild and air wrap oh and
what a lovely little way to wrap things
up I like that okay so some things I
really liked about this um number one
I'm always a fan of plane breaks and of
using horizontal planes that always
makes me happy to see and also too
seeing the uh the anti-bd uh kind of
throw there again I I am 90% sure that
he did not mean for that to be an
anti-bd but um I I I'd never see
antibits done anymore so I'm going to
take it anyway really the only thing I
have to critique about that is just is
just that turn the the step that he's
using there it's like there's that
commitment to keeping his feet just like
planted as close together as possible
and it means that he's having to contort
his feet in kind of a weird way to get
around there so I don't know I would say
may maybe a slightly smoother turn there
would be something I'd really love to
see but overall um yeah I can see why
this one became so popular and uh
definitely there's some stuff in there
that I can imagine is going to inspire a
lot of artists out there so good job
there Boris nicely done what did you
think of boris's video leave me a
comment and let me know I'd love to hear
your
[Music]
thoughts thank you so much for watching
this video it would not have been
possible without the wonderful support
of all of my patreon supporters in
particular I would like to shout out my
flow patrons who are listed on screen
right now if you'd like to check out
more of the videos that I have done
reacting to other flow artists videos I
will include a link to a playlist of
those videos down in the description and
if you'd like to support the channel I
will also include a link to my patreon
down in the description as well thanks
so much make sure to get out and flow
today yourselves and I'll see you with a
new video real soon take care now peace